[Music]
in each separate thing that you do
consider the matters which come first
and those which follow after and only
then approach the thing itself
otherwise at the start you will come to
it enthusiastically
because you've never reflected upon any
of the subsequent steps
but later on when some difficulties
appear you will give up disgracefully
do you wish to win an olympic victory so
do i by the gods for it is a fine thing
but consider the matters which come
before that and those which follow after
and only when you have done that put
your hand to the task
you have to submit to discipline follow
a strict diet give up sweet cakes train
under compulsion at a fixed hour in heat
or in cold you must not drink cold water
nor wine just whenever you feel like it
you must have turned yourself over to
your trainer precisely as you would to a
physician then when the contest comes on
you have to dig in beside your opponent
and sometimes dislocate your wrist
sprain your ankle swallow quantities of
sand take a scourging and along with all
that get beaten
after you have considered all these
points
go on into the games if you still wish
to do so otherwise you will be turning
back like children
sometimes they play wrestlers again
gladiators again they blow trumpets and
then act to play
so you too are now an athlete now a
gladiator then a rhetorician then a
philosopher
yet with your whole soul nothing but
like an ape you imitate whatever you see
and one thing after another strikes your
fancy
for you have never gone out after
anything with circumspection nor after
you had examined it all over but you
acted haphazard and half-heartedly
in the same way when some people have
seen a philosopher and heard someone
speaking like euphrates although indeed
who can speak like him
they wish to be philosophers themselves
man consider first the nature of the
business and then learn your own natural
ability if you are able to bear it do
you wish to be a contender in the
pentathlon or a wrestler look to your
arms your thighs see what your loins are
like for one man has a natural talent
for one thing another for another
do you suppose you could eat in the same
fashion drink in the same fashion give
way to impulse into irritation just as
you do now
you must keep vigils work hard abandon
your own people be despised by a paltry
slave be laughed to scorn by those who
meet you in everything get the worst of
it in honor in office in court in every
paltry affair
look these drawbacks over carefully if
you are willing at the price of these
things to secure tranquility freedom and
calm
otherwise do not approach philosophy
don't act like a child now a philosopher
later on a tax gatherer and then a
rhetorician than a pro-curator of the
caesar
these things do not go together you must
be one person either good or bad you
must labor to improve either your own
governing principle or externals you
must work hard either on the inner man
or on things outside that is play either
the role of a philosopher or else that
of a lay man
chapter 29 has to do with choosing what
we today call a lifestyle in the broad
sense
and really sticking with it following it
through all the way and stoicism can be
a lifestyle or it can become a major
component of one's lifestyle and in
doing so there's there's certain things
that it's going to end up ruling out if
you take it seriously if you're not just
being a kind of dilettante about it
which is precisely what epictetus is
calling our attention to the dangers of
dilettantism in this chapter
so he says and this is the general
advice in each separate thing that you
do
consider the matters which come first
and those would follow after and only
then approach the thing itself so think
about what the prerequisites are what
you need to do if you want to be doing
that thing right if you want to be
engaging in that kind of lifestyle if
you want it to become part of who you
are and you to become part of what it is
then also think about what has to come
after that what the entailments are or
the implications the things that come
along with it and this includes not only
what that activity requires but also
what it rules out what it's going to
make impossible for you
so if you do this then you'll be able to
commit wholeheartedly to something
you'll be able to go all in as we say
so he says otherwise at the start what's
the danger you'll come to it
enthusiastically because you've never
reflected on any of the subsequent steps
but later on when some difficulties
appear you will give up disgracefully
and how many times do we see people
doing this it can be with exercise
programs it can be with the latest diet
it can be with learning a language it
can be with mending relationships with
family members or friends it can be
about writing the novel and we can go on
and on and on and on right sometimes
unfortunately it even happens in
education so that people enter into
college uh not quite understanding why
they're going to college and about
halfway through or sometimes even the
first semester through they end up
dropping out
often bringing along with them a trail
of loans and and other uh losses along
the way and we can say this about
relationships too you're going to jump
into a romantic relationship uh think
very carefully about you know what's
going on
and what you would like to happen and
what is likely to happen those aren't
always the same thing what's what you'd
like to happen what is likely to happen
they don't map on to each other quite
perfectly
now epictetus
uses an example from athletic training
he says
do you wish to win an olympic victory
well now who of us wouldn't want to win
an olympic victory right and something
or another now we've got olympics that
have so many different sports perhaps
there's even something for for one of us
and he says so do i by the gods for it
is a fine thing
but consider the matters which come
before that and those which follow after
and only when you've done that put your
hand to the task if you want to talk all
this you know stuff about i could i
could be an olympic athlete well
consider what that would actually
involve on your part what would it take
for you to be an olympic athlete
he says well you have to submit to
discipline
okay right there
that's going to rule some people out
you have to submit to training right
escasis
follow a strict diet okay that too
especially for those of us who love to
eat
may be a problem
what else give up sweet cakes okay
that's kind of a silly example
train under compulsion at a fixed hour
in heat or cold
so
it's not just that you go to the gym
once a day when you feel like going to
the gym you're going to have a trainer
and that trainer is going to say get
here at five in the morning and we're
going to do sprints and you don't want
to do sprints tough you're doing them
right any of you who've been in in
middle school or high school athletics
probably had coaches who pushed you like
that and so you know what that's like
you must not drink cold water nor wine
whenever you feel like it you must have
turned yourself over to your trainer
precisely as you would to a physician
physicians in ancient greek times were
kind of you know pretty hands-on you
didn't just go see the doctor
and then you know do you get on the
scale and the doctor says well you need
to lose some weight and maybe you know
cut back on the
the red meat and the fats and quit
smoking and quit drinking and all this
sort of stuff and then you don't see the
doctor for another six months no your
physician would be somebody who would be
there saying hey you're not supposed to
eat that hey you need to exercise right
now hey no smoking you know all of these
sorts of things well they weren't
smoking in greek times but you get the
idea
so then that's just the start
now what is it like when you actually
participate he says when the contest
comes on you have to dig in beside your
opponent sometimes dislocate your wrist
sprain your ankle
swallow quantities of sand this would be
if you're a wrestler right sometimes
take a scourging and along with all that
after all of that
lose
get beaten
the verb here is uh nikkei thing uh yeah
nikkeith and i meaning the other guy
wins the victory you don't win the
victory right after all of that work and
we can say the same thing oh you're
gonna go to you're gonna become a big
business person right go go do your ba
now go do your mba and don't do it just
anywhere go to harvard or go to you know
uh this place or that place or that
place right i'm not really keen on
figuring out which business school is
supposed to be better than the others uh
they probably don't don't matter all
that much
um but you have to do all this sort of
stuff now do your internships now do
this now do that and you can get out
there and still not find the job that
you want waiting for you
all these things are possible
the this is how we should think about
matters in life so he says
if you've considered all these points go
into the games if you still wish to do
so
think it through it's not saying don't
be an olympic athlete just think it
through
are you really up to it not just up to
it physically but mentally
are you up to all the things that would
be involved if you are more power to you
go ahead and do it
now if you don't do things that way
what's the problem he tells us
otherwise you'll be turning back like
children what do children do and this is
fine for children at the age that
children are doing this by the way he's
not knocking children and saying oh stop
doing that you should all be adults
it's just that adults should be adults
and so he says what do children do
sometimes they play wrestlers again
gladiators again they blow trumpets then
act at play so you too now here's the
problem you too the adult are now an
athlete now a gladiator then a
rhetorician then a philosopher yet with
your whole soul
nothing
you're not committing to anything
entirely uh you want to learn a foreign
language fine learn a foreign language
uh you know spend an hour a day
doing drills and and studying things
maybe you buy yourself you know one of
these packages that they sell online and
have all these great ads about how
they're not going to make you do drills
see if that works for you it doesn't
work for you do it the old-fashioned way
put in the time every day now start
reading some text you want to learn some
latin you got to read some some latin
texts start with somebody easy aim for
augustine or cicero down the line right
or or some other great author and just
keep plowing at it but don't pretend
just because you're carrying around a
wheel lock teach yourself latin book
that you're actually learning latin
because you go in the cafe and put her
around for an hour on a saturday and
then go back to doing whatever it was
that you know you were doing i mean if
you think about this um what is it that
most people are particularly good at in
our culture there's their jobs right and
then there's say watching netflix or
enjoying themselves people can negotiate
all sorts of things online you know they
can find that movie that obscure movie
by using the google search engine to you
know zero in on it but now
what about doing actual research
you know what was the progression of the
stoic philosophers and which ones do you
need to read you can use google for that
too you know but it all depends on where
you commit yourself what are you going
to commit yourself to
what is valuable to you so he says um
you know if you do this you're like like
an ape you're imitating whatever you see
and one thing after another strikes your
fancy you're being driven by things
coming from the outside not setting your
own purposes and he says for you've
never gone out
after anything with circumspection nor
after you examined it all over it but
you act at haphazard and half-heartedly
and it's perfectly understandable that
that you know you would do that that a
person would do that if you've never
sat down and planned things out
that takes some some doing and if you
come from a family where people don't do
that sort of thing or that's just part
of the culture that you grew up in
that's unfortunate but you have a choice
at this point in time are you going to
continue down the path or are you now
going to change it
and think things through and decide do i
want to when i'm 40 years old live this
kind of lifestyle or live this kind of
lifestyle do i want to when it comes to
studying philosophy do i really want to
study philosophy and understand it or do
i want to just have a kind of a
smattering of it and bring it up every
so often and sort of catch phrases these
are possibilities one is easy to do the
other one requires something like
training for the the athletic contest
so he says in the same way when people
have heard a philosopher and heard
somebody speaking like euphrates we
don't know much about him but it would
be cool
if we did they wish to be philosophers
themselves and that's a fine thing you
know we we see other people doing things
we watch dances with the stars and we're
like oh man i wish i could dance like
that we watched some some martial arts
movie and then we started thinking oh
man i should get back into martial arts
we see some spy movie and we're like oh
i wish i knew all these languages and i
could rappel from you know these heights
and do all you know spinning kicks and
stuff like that so he says
consider the nature of the business
then learn your own natural ability if
you are
able to bear it
do you want to be a contender in the
penta pentathlon or a wrestler look to
your arms your thighs see what your
loins look like
for one man has a natural talent for one
thing another for another we're not all
meant for the same thing now of course
when it comes to stoic philosophy not
everybody necessarily has the talent to
become an expositor a teacher of stoic
philosophy
but we all have the capacity to practice
it and to learn it if we so choose
that's one of the great things about
this kind of philosophy it's very
democratic in that respect so he says
you know do you think you can keep on
living the same way if you want to
become a wrestler no you have to do
other things what about for stoicism
do you suppose you can eat in the same
fashion drink in the same fashion
no the answer is you can't
not if you want to be a stoic and that's
just the start of it
give way to impulse into irritation as
you do now
you can't keep on doing that you're
going to keep doing that but you have to
keep yourself as best you can from doing
it and then afterwards look at yourself
and say oh
i lost my temper instead of saying yeah
it's that guy's fault over there and and
once more i ought to go kick him or
something like that you say to yourself
oh i lost my temper this is not
according to my plan of life i actually
set myself behind just as much as an
athlete who you know because the weekend
came went out got drunk and you know ate
like crap and didn't do any exercise
that's the equivalent for stoic
philosophy he says you must keep vigils
work hard abandon your own people be
despised by a paltry slave be laughed to
scorn by those who meet you in
everything at the worst of it in honor
in office and court and every paltry
affairs
now this is admittedly not what every
single stoic encounters but these are
the things that can happen
um
studying stoic philosophy is not going
to make you a big name in whatever
circuit you're in
it's also not going to be something that
other people look to and say oh wow that
is so admirable except in a they'll do
that sometimes in a superficial way
until they know something about stoic
philosophy
they're not going to look at you the way
they do at the celebrities or at the
people who have a lot of money or at the
people who have uh you know beautiful
bodies or the people who have lots and
lots of connections stoic philosophy is
something that you do for yourself so he
says look these drawbacks over carefully
if you are willing at the price of these
things to secure
what is the goal tranquility freedom
and calm apathea
alluteria
atraxia these are sort of the trifecta
of what stoics are after
so if that's really your goal if that's
the far off distant goal post
then you have to train to reach it
he says otherwise don't approach
philosophy don't act like a child
and now a philosopher later on a tax
gatherer then a rhetorician then a
pro-creator of caesar these things don't
go together
you must be and here's where it gets
really uh interesting you must be one
person
you're you're stuck with that you've
only got one you to work with
so is it going to be a good you or is it
going to be a bad you or is it going to
be a you that's just sort of scattered
all over the place a different form of
bad actually from the stoic perspective
but a more unfortunate type in certain
ways right a bad person who's
deliberately bad you know where they
stand the bad person who's just
scattered all over all sorts of stuff
and frittering their life and their time
away
doesn't realize that that's going on
you want to be a good person you have to
be one person and then you have to train
yourself towards goodness
so he says you must labor to improve
either your own governing principle
or externals
you're going to work on your finances or
you're going to work on your governing
principle are you going to work on your
circle of friends and making all sorts
of connections and networking or are you
going to work on your principles are you
going to work on you know making your
body as attractive as possible or you're
going to work on your governing
principle we could go on and on and on
with examples of that great another
great example you're going to work on
your political career or you're going to
work on your governing principle these
are not compatible with each other you
only have so much time
and so much attention that you can
devote
so where are you going to spend it and
if you're going to try to you know
spread it over everything
you're not going to get anything in in
the process so he says
either work on the inner person or on
things outside that is play either the
role of the philosopher or that of the
layperson the idiots in in greek you
have to make a decision so the good news
is you actually get to make that
decision nobody else gets to make it for
you
our duties are in general measured by
our social relationships he is a father
one is called upon to take care of him
to give way to him in all things to
submit when he reviles or strikes you
but he is a bad father
did nature then bring you into a
relationship with a good father no but
simply with a father
my brother does me wrong
very well then maintain the relation
that you have towards him and do not
consider what he is doing but what you
will have to do if your moral purpose is
to be in harmony with nature
for no one will harm you without your
consent
you will have been harmed only when you
think you are harmed
in this way therefore you will discover
what duty to expect of your neighbor
your citizen your commanding officer if
you acquire the habit of looking at your
social relations with them
chapter 30 is a passage that i think
proves difficult for a lot of people to
to accept in our culture for several
different reasons
one of these has to do with the fact
that he's connecting morality and what
is right for us to do
with our roles and our relationships you
know he says straight out our duties our
cafe
that's a stoic term for duty are in
general measured
by our social relationships he's not
saying that all of our duties are
you know developing out of social
relationships but that a great many of
them are he says host epiphan you know
in in the generality and
this this has to do with our uh sc our
our uh
our relationships are our connections
with other people a lot of these have to
do with determinate roles that we
inhabit many of which we don't choose he
talks about for example
fathers and children we don't choose to
be a child of somebody
unless we're going through some really
strange you know uh you know
re-parenting ritual or something like
that for the most part that's not really
the way it works we get the parents that
we've got and we're stuck with them
parents you know you can say well
parents chose to make children but
sometimes that's actually true but they
don't really choose the children that
they get and you know we can say the
same thing with siblings we can say the
same thing with so many relationships
that we're thrown into
and so there's there's kind of an
arbitrariness to it that i think a lot
of people have have trouble with
there's also some worries about the fact
that his isn't all this culturally
relative
that's an issue that you know is a big
issue uh can be worked out separately
the the short answer is no most cultures
have some sense of parentage and
children
and you know how they should behave with
each other let's not say that everything
is totally constant but there's a lot of
similarities that you can look at across
the board
the other thing that i think people
really have a hard time with is they
look at this and they think that
epictetus is saying that whatever
whatever the other person does to you in
the relationship
you have to accept it you can't lay down
any boundaries you can't lay down any
limits and so it seems like there's a
possibility for abuse so it's worth
keeping in mind that the stoic is not
going to allow themselves to suffer
something that truly is abusive not only
because
it would be damaging to oneself it would
place oneself under you know
a burden that would make it very
difficult to practice the stoic
lifestyle
but it's also not good for the other
person
the other person who's being an abuser
that's not good for them that's
fundamentally bad for them and so
sometimes by removing yourself from the
situation and laying down limits and
saying i'd love to be a you know your
kid but you're really uh too much with
this this stuff that you're doing and
you're going to have to knock that off
before we can have a healthy
relationship that would be allowable
within this um but there there is before
you reach that point a lot of like
putting up with the other person's
nonsense in part because if you're a
stoic realize they're not a stoic right
and maybe you can talk to them and say
hey you know wouldn't you like to live a
life where you're not feeling
upset all the time and then taking it
out on me in this way
but you can't make them do that
that's not something in your control
what is in your control
is whether you fulfill your duties
and how you do it and
how you understand the role that you're
in
so he says
our duties are in general measured by
our social relationships
this person's a father so what are you
called to do to take care of him to give
way to him in all things to submit when
he reviles or strikes you and again i
think that for quite a few of us we
would say some of these parts are
culturally
limited or relative
but some of them aren't you know
respecting one's parents
may not necessarily mean that you agree
with everything that they say in our
culture which prizes a lot of you know
back and forth talking and stuff like
that but in other cultures it might mean
that or bringing things up at the right
time not embarrassing your parents by
say correcting them in public
there's a lot of ways of doing this
now notice what he says after that and
this is the the complaint but he's a bad
father and epictetus says well did
nature bring you into relationship with
a good father no simply a father
the roles that we're in
we don't get to choose
how the other person behaves in that
role that's up to that person that's not
up to us
in a way it takes a lot of pressure off
to say i don't need to worry about
making that other person do something
that they're not going to do and my
myself being vaxter upset by it
children it works the same way too
people are always trying to get their
kids to behave some kids just won't
behave or they'll behave in this
circumstance but not in that
circumstance it's pretty common um if
you invest most of your energy and
making sure that your children stay
all within the lines that's really a
quixotic enterprise and you're going to
be very disappointed
somewhere down the line
so he says
maintain the relationship that you have
towards this father
don't worry don't consider what he is
doing but what you will have to do if
your moral purpose is to be in harmony
with nature the goal for you is to
maintain your prayer races your faculty
of choice your moral purpose in
accordance with nature you do that by
fulfilling your roles towards other
people not worrying about whether
there's reciprocity not worrying about
whether they did something first and
whether you're going to get back at them
by withdrawing the role we could say
this about so many other things we could
say this about marriages and you know
how the partners in the marriage treat
each other it's very common for you know
little subterranean wars to break out
where one person well you didn't do that
so i'm gonna take something away over
here
that would be to go against the stoic uh
philosophy on on these sorts of matters
same thing with with friends same thing
with classmates same thing with all
sorts of other relationships so he says
nobody can harm you without your consent
you will only you will been harmed only
when you think you are harmed now to go
back to the abuse thing you know if
somebody really is being abusive let's
say they're they're constantly insulting
you tearing you down
um i don't think epictetus would say
well you have to stay in that
relationship and just let them do
whatever they want to you because
stoicism
no that's not what stoicism consists in
it recognizes us as human beings who are
very often even if perhaps you know
theoretically we shouldn't be affected
by what other people do when it's
parents who are doing it it's very tough
to screen that out so if we know
that we're having trouble with that or
we know that because of the way they
treated us long ago that never got
talked about or resolved that you know
we're having difficulty in in you know
seeing them in the light that we should
see them and they're still driving us
nuts uh because they're not changing not
recognizing things not apologizing then
it may be that we do have to set down a
boundary and we do have to say okay
i recognize that that in theory
nobody can harm me without my consent
but i'm finding myself giving consent to
that and i want to stop doing that
so he goes on and he says
in this way by thinking about our duties
and our relationships we will discover
what duty to expect
of our neighbor
our citizen
our commanding officer
if we acquire the habit of looking at
our social relations
with them if we look at our
skeptis in greek with them
we we can think about how we ought to
comport ourselves in relation to other
people by looking at the nature of that
relationship and that's not to say that
there can't be anything personalized
about it that we have to reduce it just
to a role oh you're my superior so i
have to behave towards you in this way
we can have a personal relationship but
there is that role there
and keeping our
moral purpose in accordance with nature
does uh have something to do with that
it's not as if our social roles are just
things that we
uh put on like clothes and then then
take off they are the fabric within
which we live so we really want to pay
attention to them because they matter
for moral life
[Music]
you